das ist wirklich erschreckend ein
reporter hat sich als krebs bei den
ausgegeben und bei verschiedenen
alternativ medizinern und medizinerinnen
in ganz deutschland um rat gesucht
die ergebnisse sind eine absolute
katastrophe viele therapievorschläge
sind oft nicht nur teuer und windows
sondern können sogar lebensgefährlich
enden
diese alarmierenden ergebnisse dieser
investigative recherche zu alternativen
medizin jetzt im pixum science fiction
und abschluss habe ich noch ein kleines
geschenk für euch also herzlich
willkommen vor drei jahren mit mein
bruder gestorben er wurde 56 jahre alt
er könnte heute noch leben hätte er
nicht auf anraten eines heilpraktikers
für seine große show nierenentzündung
so wichtige berlin im alter von 25
jahren abgesetzt kurz darauf kollabierte
sanieren er musste im krankenhaus in
ihrem hörte auf zu arbeiten wenn er
nicht sofort an die dialyse gekommen
wäre also an die blutwäsche wäre er
innerhalb von kürzester zeit gestorben
bei diesem tag muss er drei mal in der
woche an die dialyse maschine die sein
blut gereinigt hat das macht sie aber
nicht so gut wie nieren also wie die
echten nieren so dass der körper nach
30 jahren dann doch vergiftet ist er
kann nicht mehr mein bruder ist
gestorben
und das ist kein einzelfall steve jobs
den apple gründer ist was genau so
gegangen
aber dazu später mehr weil solche
fälle keine einflüsse der wind hat ein
reporter jetzt getestet wie es ihm mit
einer schlimmen krankheit bei den
alternativ medizinern und medizinerinnen
gegangen wäre
die diagnose krebs genauer ein hodgkin
lymphom also ein tumor der die
lymphknoten befällt die chemotherapie
vor einem jahr hat ingrid zwar
kurzzeitig zurück gedrängt doch nun
ist er wieder da der patient ist 33
jahre jung und er hat keine symptome in
geht es soweit gut sein arzt sagt es
führe kein weg an einer zweiten
chemotherapie vorbei
doch diesmal müsse eine deutlich
höhere dosierung her diese diagnose
infektion ausgedacht von meinem kollegen
riskierte er arbeitet für korrektiv an
gemeinnützige frischezentrum er will
mit seiner recherche herausfinden was
alternativmediziner und medizinerinnen
in ganz deutschland zu krebskranken
patienten wie ihm seine recherche ist
spannend und alarmieren zugleich denn
ihr ist leidet nur zum schein viel zu
viele wirklich todkranke menschen aber
begeben sich zusammen
praktikant sogenannten neu germanischen
doktoren und geistheiler oft in dem
glauben dass diese ihre letzte hoffnung
seien schätzungen zufolge geben die
deutschen jährlich milliarden von euro
aus um sich mit alternativen methoden
behandeln zu lassen die zahl der
heilpraktiker hat sich in den
vergangenen 30 jahren fast verzehnfacht
die alternativmedizin also boomt und es
ist kein ende abzusehen im gegenteil
schätzung zufolge nimmt jeder zweite
krebspatient alternative
gesundheitsleistungen in anspruch
zurück zur riskio und seiner
investigativen recherche von einer
kollegin bekommt er einen diagnose brief
ausgestellt und eine dvd mit
computertomographien die deutlich zeigen
dass eine fiktive krebserkrankung nun
auch die milz angegriffen hat ein klares
indiz für die schulmedizin auf eine
chemotherapie zu setzen
natürlich etwas unangenehmen hat viele
nebenwirkungen doch im fall finden vom
stehen die heilungschancen mit einer
chemotherapie
da sehen die sehr gut auf ohne dagegen
gehen wie gegen uns also der tod
beim ersten besuch hatte in einer klinik
mit dem schriftzug biologische
krebsmedizin auf dem eingangsschild der
praxis der dort ansässige art wird sich
seine krankheitsgeschichte an und legt
ihnen seine sogenannte diagnose reihe in
seiner klinik am herz der kosten vom
für fünf tage inklusive der
empfohlenen elektromagnetischen
messungen für den energiehaushalt
einzelner organe diese ergebnisse
würden dem arzt an den therapie weg
vorgeben in betracht kämen
zitat hypnose homöopathie vitamin b 17
infusionen eine sogenannte fiber
therapie wäre zusätzlich sinnvoll
wir würden ihm abgestorbene bakterien
gespritzt werden
die ratio franken arzt nach seiner
einschätzung was die chemotherapie
angeht sollte er diese zusätzlich zu
diesen alternativen therapie
vorschlägen machen ja oder nein
die antwort des arztes die entscheidung
müsse er von seinem inneren herr
treffen denn schließlich kenne ja auch
die erkrankung von innen so dass auch
die heilung von innen her kommen müsse
diese worte treffen irritiert denn in
diesen worten schwingt seinem gefühl
nach ein indirekter vorwurf an ihn
selbst mit eine schuldzuweisung an den
patienten stimmt etwas mit
neben seinem charakter seiner
lebensweise nicht etwas grundlegendes
soll das also die erklärung für eine
krebserkrankung sein
dabei ist doch biomedizinische klar dass
krebs dadurch entsteht dass zellen
mutieren und zum tumor bucher am ende
dann der vorschlag des arztes die
chemotherapie zu verschieden
seine therapie nämlich könne helfen
alles beiseite zu schieben was die
heilung verhindern also angst ablenkung
und giftstoffe der kostenpunkt des
hauses euro für viele patienten und
patientinnen die alternative medizin in
anspruch nehmen nicht unbedingt
abschreckend experten experten in diesem
bereich haben die beobachtung machen
können je höher der preis für die
behandlung desto höher die
glaubwürdigkeit der heiler und heilerin
je mehr also der patient bezahlen muss
desto sinnvoller stufte er die
behandlungsmethode 1
der zweite alternative ab während
christoph recherche recht dem
vermeintlich krebskranken patienten
nicht direkt von der chemotherapie ab
sinnvoll sei es aber diese zwei wochen
aufzuschieben eine wärmetherapie sei
sinnvoll bei dem der tumor lokal erhitzt
kostenpunkt 8000 euro und die
nebenwirkungen einer chemotherapie seien
natürlich nicht ohne
und weiter wortwörtlich die tat also
nicht raus zögern nicht dass die medien
schuld geben und sagen ich habe die
chemotherapie verzögert diesen satz hat
krebs im laufe seiner rassel so oder so
ähnlich des öfteren gehört
es ist wohl die masse der heiler sich
abzusichern denn gesetzlich festgelegt
ist bringen sie die patienten und
patientinnen von einer chemotherapie ab
hätten den verbliebenen die chance den
zu verklagen
derjenige der einem jungen menschen mit
einer heilungschance von 50 prozent von
einer rettenden methode update kann
wegen körperverletzung und arglistiger
täuschung angeklagt wird und genau hier
liegt das problem
vor gericht wird kaum eine strafe
durchgesetzt denn die angehörigen haben
oft bessere dinge zu tun als nach einem
trauerfall vor gericht zu streiten hinzu
kommen dass viele richter ihr urteil
nach dem motto selbst schuld fällen
dabei gehen sie nicht dass kranke
menschen mit angst eventuelle vieles
versuchen was einen gesunden und
rational wegen den menschen erst einmal
gar nicht in den sinn kommen würde
zudem sichern sich die heiler ab und
lassen die patienten unterschreiben
die schulmedizin ablehnen die dritte
station von risco ist eine
heilpraktikerin die sich auf die
sogenannte germanische neue medizin
spezialisiert hat regel gert hahne ein
ehemaliger arzt hat diese theorie
begründet und zwar als reaktion auf die
jüdische schulmedizin völlig zu recht
hat er dann später seine ärztliche
zulassung verloren seine theorien
töteten im endeffekt mehrere seiner
patienten
die heilpraktikerin selbst hält rückl
gerhard hammer für verrückt
praktiziert jedoch seine theorien eine
krankheit sei ausdruck des körpers
eines konflikts kranke menschen können
ihre aufgestaute energie die
beispielsweise durch mobbing entsteht
und dann krank macht jedoch nicht frei
setzen anders als tiere beispielsweise
die gegeneinander kämpfen
ihre reaktion auf erich jooß
krankheitsbild krebs an sich gebe es
erstmal nicht man gehe bei ihm erst
einmal von einem an geschwollenen
lymphknoten am hals auf eine niederlage
am arbeitsplatz sei schuld daran den
kranken bericht über fliegt wie nur
erkundigt sich dagegen äußerst
detailreich nachher ist usa zu schwitzen
das fazit chemotherapie seien nicht zu
empfehlen stattdessen dafür aus berlin
wegziehen zu seinen eltern soll die
empfehlung bezüglich der chemotherapie
war auch hier übrigens wieder so
schwammig formuliert dass man auch
dieser heilpraktikerin rechtlich gesehen
nichts anhaben könnte dabei schätzt
die schulmedizin die heilungschancen
eben solcher patienten mit chemotherapie
als sehr gut heim ohne dagegen bringt
sie auf 0 hatten wir uns jetzt einmal
ganz klar zu sagen ein patient der sich
auf diesen rat verlassen hätte würde
wohl nicht mehr leben auch der nächste
besuch ist alarmierend region ist nun
patient einer geiz heilerin auch wie
rät ihnen direkt von der chemo ab und
schlägt ihm vitamin b12 als das mittel
der wahl vor
ein mittel das derzeit in dieser szene
boomt aber keinen effekt bei einer
krebserkrankung hat stattdessen sind
schon menschen an einer überdosis
gestorben
die ursache der krebserkrankung von
heristo sei das gestörte verhältnis
zwischen ihm und seinen eltern
desweiteren stecke ein trauma dahinter
denn er wisse nicht wo er hingehöre zum
weiblichen oder männlichen geschlecht
ihre empfehlung mit gott sprechen und in
einer kirche eine kerze anzünden
das eigentliche problem besteht darin
dass praktisch jede heilpraktiker oder
heilpraktikerin werden kann die
ausbildung ist kaum regeln auch viel
viel kürzer als ein medizinstudium
krankheiten wie krebs dürften sie
eigentlich gar nicht behandelt es sei
den patienten willigen ein und genau
hier liegt die krux der geschichte dann
müssen die schulmediziner und unser
gesundheitssystem auch mal selbst an die
nase packen denn offenbar besteht bedarf
an alternativen heilmethoden das was
diese heiler und heilerin auszeichnet
ist dass sie sich zeit nehmen zeit die
normale ärzte und ärzten in ihrem
stressigen alltag gar nicht haben und
das bekommen letztendlich die patienten
zu spüren die nicht viel mehr sind als
eine nummer im computer hier also
müssen kompetente ansprechpartner herr
denen die patienten vertrauen mehr noch
experten experten plädieren dafür dass
den ärzten die arztgespräche der
saniert werden denn dies würde den
alternativ medizinern und medizinerin
ihre gründer gates recherche geht
weiter bei alternativ heiler die seine
magnetische aura messen wollen denn
handystrahlung sei die ursache wird eine
krebserkrankung ein anderer heimat weiß
die regierung darauf hin dass das nun
eben eine lektion sei und es ging
schließlich nicht darum zu überleben
die nächste heilerin diagnostiziert ihm
dass schuldgefühle die ursache für den
krebs seien vitamin c in
hochkonzentrierter dosis angelegt als
biologische chemo sei die therapie für
ihn zum guten schluss will ich euch aber
eine info nicht vorenthalten in diesem
bisschen tröstlich kollege hinzu mit
der fiktiven krebserkrankung hat bei
seinen recherchen auch eine alternativ
praxis gesucht die ihn von vornherein
kompetent beraten hat eine chemotherapie
sei hier angebracht alles andere keine
option ja und die restlichen praxen
hatte ist er nach seiner recherche
übrigens kontaktiert und klargestellt
dass es sich um eine undercover aktion
gehandelt hat die antworten waren wenn
sie denn überhaupt kam mehr als
ernüchternd teilweise wurde sein
vorgehen in frage gestellt teilweise und
noch einmal explizit die einzelnen
behandlungsoptionen st kosten
aufgestellt eine weitere heilpraktikerin
bekräftigt noch einmal ihre aussagen in
etwa eine chemotherapie schade mehr als
dass sie nützen
das alles zeigt dass diese heiler und
heilerin nicht verstanden haben wovon
wir reden oder noch schlimmer sie wissen
blicken aber darüber hinweg
verantwortungsloser geht es gar nicht
als fazit von harry zur recherche kann
man nur eine sache ziehen auch die
schulmedizin ist nicht zu 1000%
allmächtig und auch wie wird oft von
der krankheit krebs besiegt auch das
system der schulmedizin hat
wirtschaftliche interessen und ist kalt
und stoff für den patienten und
patientinnen denn menschen machen nun
mal fehler auf nun studierte erste oder
selbst ernannte heiler doch fest steht
die idee der schulmedizin ist es
plausibel zu sein ihre methoden werden
ausgiebig erforscht und immer wieder
überprüft wie bei wir nicht auf der
angst der patienten und auf einzelnen
geschichten alternative heiler dagegen
wollen sich viel zu oft nur bereichern
und zwar an der angst kranker menschen
ohne dass inhaltlich irgend etwas
dahintersteckt
ach ja und steve jobs er könnte
tatsächlich heute noch leben statt sich
operieren zu lassen behandelte er
monatelang waren
bauchspeicheldrüsenkrebs mit diäten
pflanzen präparaten akupunktur
fruchtsäften und sogar einen hellseher
bemühte er bevor er sich neun monate
nach der diagnose endlich operieren
ließ das war zu spät sein todesurteil
grund war er wollte seinen körper nicht
öffnen lassen mein bruder konnte heute
auch noch leben wenn er eine
spenderniere angenommen hätte bei ihm
war die ablehnung von fremden karma das
in seinen körper eingehen wird und
tatsächlich berichten ja
transplantierte vom
persönlichkeitsveränderung aber ist
das den tod wert der kommt nämlich
unweigerlich wenn eine krankheit falsch
oder nicht behandelt wird
vielen dank an technology review in
zusammenarbeit mit dieser zeitschriften
dieses video entstanden wirklich tolle
hintergrundgeschichten gibt es in
technology review wie zb diese und
exklusiv entwicklung zuschauer habe ich
jetzt ein geschenk ihr bekommt nämlich
eine ausgabe gratis wenn ihr auf diesen
link klickt und hier geht es weiter mit
krebs vom angeheizt da geht es um ein
neues vielversprechendes verfahren gegen
den krebs klick darauf wenn es euch
interessiert und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt